Once upon a time there was a dragon named Seath, who was a bit of an ugly duckling.
His brothers all made fun of him. So he betrayed them and was rewarded by Gwyn.
Seath had a thing for Gwyn's daughter, Gwynevere.
And one day, he stuck his crystal halberd into her Gaping Dragon.
Nine months later, a child was born.
'Priscilla'
Once Priscilla had grown to adulthood many of the gods realized that she was incredibly cute.
She had a tail so fluffy that no mortal could resist petting it.
The gods recognized that she would bring many,
The gods recognized that she would bring many, many,
The gods recognized that she would bring many, many, many
The gods recognized that she would bring many, many, many one-quarter dragon babies into the world
and locked her away.
The Painted World is essentially a giant chastity belt.
But some adventurers could not resist Priscilla's allure and journeyed into the Painted World,
looking for their waifu.
'Go back, go back!'
But alas, adventurers could not go back. Because the exit was actually behind Priscilla.
Kind of pointless, really.
Why use them as warnings inside a place you can't even leave? Hm.
Anyway, finally the Chosen Undead fulfils his mission.
Every trial has led him here. And now he can claim his prize.
He can now caress the tail of Priscilla.
Many people believe that the true ending comes when you defeat Gwyn, but this is the real ending.
Thou must returneth whence thou came.
This land is peaceful, its inhabitants kind, but thou dost-
- I'm sorry, what?!
This land is peaceful, its inhabitants kind.
Are you fucking kidding me?!
You mean these guys?!
Yeah, I guess they sure are fond of my souls, you bitch.